nun haben sie ja in gewisser weise die
antwort schon selbst gegeben dass ich
dem natürlich jetzt nicht im detail vor
greifen kann und will zumal wir und das
ist die herausforderung der professor
wille auch gerade beschrieben hat über
diese feiertage natürlich jetzt auch
genauer auf die zahlen einfach schauen
müssen wodurch ergeben sich unterschiede
ist es wegen unterschiedlichen
infektionsgeschehen oder nicht
wahrscheinlicher auch wegen
meldeversäumnissen über die feiertage
gibt es macht ja die auswertung der
daten auch etwas etwas schwieriger oder
beziehungsweise die bewertung der daten
was auf jeden fall brauchen wird ganz
allgemein ist weiterhin starke kontakt
reduzierung das jedenfalls als
überschrift gilt weiterhin
und ich finde für uns alle sehr wichtig
morgen ist ja schon silvester vergisst
man ja gelegentlich wie schnell das
jetzt alles auch ins neue jahr geht
wichtig ist weiterhin dass das schließen
im öffentlichen bereich nur sinn macht
für uns alle wenn wir auch im privaten
bereich kontakte reduzieren also ich das
gehört zusammen
und deswegen ist die frage war es eben
zum beispiel morgen passiert in
deutschland oder besser nicht passiert
auch ein ganz ganz wichtiger faktor für
den weiteren verlauf und alles weitere
würde ich tatsächlich den beratungen zu
beginn nächster woche überlassen